so this week our cover story looks at
the conflict that's flared up between
India and Pakistan and in particular how
this puts India's Prime Minister
Narendra Modi on the spot this is just
the latest of many many terror attacks
that have taken place inside India
conducted by groups based in Pakistan
two weeks ago there was a terrible
terrorist attack in the Indian
controlled part of Kashmir 40 Indian
soldiers were killed in recent days mr.
Modi has ordered Indian airplanes into
Pakistani airspace to bomb targets there
in retaliation an aerial battle ensued
Pakistan and India both claimed to have
shot down one another's planes Pakistan
captured an Indian pilot this is the
first time since 1971 that planes have
been crossing into the airspace of the
the other country and bombing targets
within it but of course this time around
India and Pakistan both have nuclear
weapons so the situation is that much
more dangerous the big question now is
whether the two sides are able to back
down or whether the sort of spiral of
escalation continues the thing that
makes this situation particularly
combustible is the fact that India is
facing an election in April at the last
election campaign mr. Modi
sold himself as a big reformer who would
bring jobs to India that hasn't quite
worked out as planned though the economy
has grown unemployment has risen and as
a sort of broad dissatisfaction amongst
a lot of voters with the state of the
economy and then he also has as his sort
of foot soldiers in the campaign Hindu
nationalist activists who feel that mr.
Modi hasn't done enough to advance a
strong Pro Hindu anti-muslim agenda
Hindus are 80% of the population in
India and obviously the temptation for
any politician is to try to appeal to
them because that will automatically
help at the ballot box
mr. Modi is an avowed li nationalist
politician he has a particularly
carefully cultivated such tough-guy
persona there's all kinds of pressure on
him to to try and appear resolute and
strong not back down teach the
Pakistanis a lesson that's the kind of
rhetoric he uses all the time on the
campaign trail and that pressure
obviously could could result in a
stronger reaction that could lead the
two countries further down this this
spiral of conflict having said that
there are some signs that neither
country wants the conflict to escalate
Western countries have tried to sort of
take India on to a different course of
diplomatic course try to raise this in
the Security Council get Kandam nations
of the terrorist group and of Pakistan
support for it there in the Security
Council to try and bring this on to a
diplomatic track and and and defuse the
tensions and certainly you know for the
safety of India that's the thing that
mr. Modi needs to do he needs to step
back from the conflict